the Joe Rogan experience okay so what's
your take on what we're going through
right now Dan for everybody in the
future this is a day it's basically a
month into like extreme coronavirus
lockdown for the country it all started
sort of in the beginning of March now
here we are in the first week of April
and everybody's stir-crazy and weirded
out by this
including me yeah and I'm sure you as
well what what is your take on this Wow
gun really speaking I remember I
remember the weekend where everything
all of a sudden shifted it was the March
14th weekend I remember that weekend
because it was my birthday and I
remember how everybody was basically
still going out to bars and restaurants
and then all of a sudden everything
changed I think the entire paradigm
changed and I could go through a long
timeline of how we got there there's a
lot of finger-pointing right now a lot
of opportunism the reality is a lot of
us didn't there pretty much everybody
didn't know a whole lot and then we
ended up in this situation where and now
my general take on it we we are in a
what I would call a tactical retreat so
I'm gonna use a military term there to
describe what we are doing we all of the
sudden ran into a hail of gunfire okay
like and I think about this in military
terms we're on patrol we run into a hail
of gunfire we're not really sure what
hit us we have a basic idea we know who
they are we know generally what the
enemy is but we weren't quite sure how
to combat it so we took a retreat
tactically speaking that retreat looks a
lot like a lockdown okay don't talk to
anybody don't don't touch anybody
maintain that social distancing lock
things down we have to slow the spread
and allow our backup our public health
system to catch up at a certain point we
have to come out of that tactical pause
we have to come out of that retreat and
start engaging in the enemy a little bit
now we do that slowly when we do it
carefully and so I think that's the I
like to look at it that way as the
conversation about how to reopen society
at a certain point we have to move away
from risk containment and room move into
a risk mitigation strategy and we're
ramping up our production of things like
ventilators of PPE of testing capability
in order to do that
now there's some talk of when this is
gonna end and I don't know how you even
make that distinction how does one make
a decision and it seems like one of
those things where once it starts once
you lock a country down and tell people
stay away stay home don't go to work
don't do anything unless it's very
essential like grocery stores hospitals
media there's certain things that are
allowed to be done right now when does
that end and how does one decide when
that ends yeah there's a lot of
different ways to think about that you
from from the public health perspective
I hear them say certain things like
after 14 days of a downward trend in
cases then we can start reopening when
the are is less than 1 then you can
start reopening so our being less than 1
means for every contagious person they
infect less than one other person right
now that numbers are at just over 2 ok
so there's there's an obvious spread
that occurs that I have I think those
are valid assumptions I definitely
question using those as our standards I
would like to see us use other standards
as well
such as are we at a point where we're
testing it up and we have enough
ventilators and hospital bed space and
PPE to actually fight the virus
alongside reopening there our society
because I think we have to come to terms
with a very certain truth which is we
cannot indefinitely lock down those
costs are enormous and they're not just
cost to our 401ks and our jobs I mean
there's a public health cost there too
you know I speak with doctors here in
Houston we don't we don't have a huge
case number in Houston where our
hospitals are like 50 percent empty
right now and they can't do much-needed
surgeries procedures because you know
what's called an elective surgery is
gonna be kind of a gray area so a lot of
stuff isn't getting done from a public
health side also there's there's there's
I think the obvious public health crisis
when people don't have jobs there's
divorce rates there's suicides we have
to really take all of this into account
as we as we talk about when to reopen
society
[Applause]